hola que tal bienvenidos a este castor
cibernético de este viernes 9 de marzo
en vivo y en directo por facebook live
pero también en youtube y en nuestro
sitio
rcn punto sea un caluroso saludo a todas
y todos y gracias por su agradable
compañía les recordamos que este
programa lo podrán escuchar también en
nuestro sitio internet este viernes
mismo 9 de marzo el sábado 10 y el
domingo 11 esta versión tendrá la música
agregada que no le ponemos en el
programa en directo porque bueno por
problemas de facebook y de derechos de
autor
entonces en el programa que encontrarán
este viernes el sábado y el domingo en
la versión audio estará la música del
programa que está hoy estará a cargo del
grupo de música instrumental de toronto
que se llama battle of santiago
un caluroso saludo a todas y todos y
gracias por su agradable compañía louis
bienvenido muchas gracias señor que tal
como está muy bien y para los que estén
sorprendidos por allá y por acá los que
estén sorprendidos de vernos reducidos
sino a la mínima expresión a algo muy
cercano de la mínima expresión lo que
ocurre es que nuestro webmaster leonardo
key menú se tomó libre esta semana
porque es la semana de las vacaciones
escolares entonces se quedó con sus
niños en nuestra colega leonora chapman
está de vacaciones
nuestro colega rufo valència está
ausente por fuerza mayor entonces pero
la realidad está presente pero la
calidad que está presente a nuestro
colega ruffo
a nuestro colega leonardo gimeno lo
reemplaza hoy
en la transmisión en directo en facebook
live de este programa sube ir ya así que
es el webmaster de la sección jarabe
blanc wa sahlan súper
y como se dieron cuenta pues estamos
decíamos fuera de micro en agradable
compañía pues aquí están yo les presento
nuestras invitadas de hoy marianna marín
fundadora y directora general del
instituto latinoamericano de transmisión
de la lengua y la cultura legados
bienvenida mariana muchísimas gracias y
acompaña a mariana lucia aguero
coordinadora de español en legados y
también profesor en la facultad
latinoamericana de ciencias sociales
flacso de buenos aires- bienvenida
lúcida muchas gracias y bueno pues
mariana y lucia están con nosotros
durante todo el programa y vamos a
hablar justamente delegados pero antes
antes de entrar en materia con nuestras
invitadas vamos a comenzar este castor
cibernético como lo estamos haciendo de
costumbre hablando de algún tema o
alguna noticia
no sé si ustedes vayan refrescando la
memoria si tienen alguna noticia que
haya que las haya impactado esta semana
si no no se propagó fuera de lo
convencional
lo convencional
bueno a lo mejor y tú lo hice
tú tienes algo en particular y
notificando como estamos en una semana
que está de hecho gobernada porque esto
de alguna manera con el tema de el día
internacional de la mujer hoy viene como
anillo al dedo de la noticia de que por
primera vez en su historia la real
policía montada canadiense ayer se va a
tener a partir de ahora una jefa interés
de un jefe es la primera vez en su
historia es la primera vez de manera
permanente porque ya había habido una
anterior pero transitoria si no me
equivoco tengo el dato por aquí en el
año 2007 beverly vos o no había sido
jefa pero con con carácter
no permanente digamos en el caso si se
trata de alguien que acaba de ser
nombrada es brenda al aquí que a partir
de hoy será entonces jefa de la real
policía montada canadiense
ella tiene 31 años de experiencia
de edad porque me parece un poco para el
servicio para el cargo no quiere decir
que los jóvenes no sean capaces en
mirarnos a nosotros jóvenes ser somos
capaces cuenta con medallas de las
fuerzas de protección de naciones unidas
también ha sido entregado a una medalla
por parte de los cascos azules
canadienses y llega el momento especial
para el cuerpo ya que está sacudido
todavía hoy en día por los escándalos de
abuso sexual de sólo unas filas entonces
se presume que la presencia de una mujer
a la cabeza de la fuerza va a poder
ayudar a limpiar la situación del cuerpo
y a sacudir ahí la caja
para que para que no haya pues esas esas
alegaciones de las que ha venido siendo
el blanco la gendarmería real seriamente
entonces por primera vez en su historia
de manera permanente una mujer es jefa
de la real policía montada canadiense
bueno que bien por felicitaciones
felicitaciones yo sigo en la misma vena
del día internacional de la mujer y es
algo que me pareció muy muy curioso y es
que un responsable de un restaurante
mcdonald en california en light what en
light en lynwood perdón en lingua
california
ayer para el día internacional de la
mujer
le cambió el cambio la letra de la de su
de su tienda mcdonald la puso al revés y
para poner la w que ustedes ven acá
homenaje al día internacional de la
mujer yo no sé si nuestros amigos allá
en la cámara lo pueden ver pero si no de
todas maneras vamos a ponerla en nuestro
sitio internet también fue el único la
única el único restaurante mcdonald en
todo eeuu y en américa finalmente en
haber tenido esa idea entonces lo que
sucedió fue que en las redes sociales
cuando vieron que este restaurante había
invertido la letra de mcdonald para
rendirle homenaje a la mujer y que fuera
una w entonces en las redes sociales
muchísimos alrededor de 100 restaurantes
bolt también invirtieron su m y bueno
ese fue la forma como esta cadena de
restaurantes mcdonald's le rindió
homenaje a la mujer de una decisión del
administrador de esa sucursal no de la
cadena en sí misma exacto si fue una
iniciativa personal
a la palabra woman exacto woman y bueno
y tengo otra otra esta es inédita
sí señor fue que había una pareja
allá en una pareja en australia en la en
la costa oeste de australia estaba
pasando se llama tania y kim el man
bueno pues estaban paseando en la playa
pues sí caminando
esparciéndose tomando aire fresco y todo
lo demás cuando de pronto la señora
tania vio una botella en la playa no
entonces al principio al principio ella
creyó pues que era contaminación que era
alguien que había dejado una botella ahí
pero la botella le pareció bonita y se
dijo que caería bien en su decoración en
la casa entonces la recogió
cuando recogió la botella se dio cuenta
que había un mensaje al interior de la
botella y resulta que esta botella fue
lanzada al mar hace 132 años 132 años y
fue lanzada por un barco alemán llamado
paula a 950 kilómetros al de la costa
oeste de australia en el marco de un
estudio sobre las corrientes oceánicas
entonces ese mensaje que estaba al
interior acá de la botella decía que
que el que encontrara ese mensaje lo
enviara al observatorio naval de hamburg
o o al consulado alemán más cercano
indicando dónde y cuándo habían
encontrado la botella se encontró un
poco tarde bueno 132 años pero bueno se
encontró ahora lo que se dice es que
bueno hubo expertos que empezaron a
hacer el análisis de esta de la botella
y de lo escrito y todo lo demás para
saber si se estaba allí estaba si era no
les estaban haciendo un chiste no
entonces efectivamente él
en los resultados del estudio que se
hizo es que se trataba de una botella de
ginebra holandesa y el papel era un
papel barato que databa de la segunda
mitad del siglo 19 que de hecho habla
estas personas cuando encontró la
botella primero confundieron ese mensaje
con un cigarro creyeron que era un
cigarro y estaba dentro de la misma y en
su primer intento o su primera intención
fue tirar a la basura la botella del
cigarro y después en cuenta que no era
un cigarro sino que era un papel
enrollado y cuando lo abrieron leyeron
el mensaje que vos acabas de leer es
bueno durante más de 70 años dice acá la
noticia al finales del siglo 19 y a
principios del siglo 20 alrededor de
varios centenares de botellas se
lanzaron al mar en el marco de este
estudio sobre las corrientes marinas
oceánicas que llevaba a cabo el
observatorio naval alemán y tampoco para
alentar a la gente que se lance más a
las botellas más
porque no tiene una botellita con una
botella pues a lo mejor está bien lo que
no está bien es echar bolsas plásticas
ir a la playa y dejar un reguero de
basura en la villa de que bali en
indonesia está prácticamente cubierta
por el plástico que llega con las
corrientes marinas sin grasas así que
paraíso perdido o paraíso plastificado
plastificado fíjate hay a veces unas
imágenes que vemos circular por ahí que
son verdaderamente desalentadoras porque
tú ves toda la basura que se encuentra
en el mar
ves a tortugas que comen plástico y
finalmente pues terminan muriendo porque
no se están alimentando porque creen que
son algas o qué sé yo y finalmente pues
eso es lo que no se debe tirar al mar y
ha habido un informe científico hace muy
pocos días diciendo que los animales no
pueden dejar de comercio plástico porque
lo confunde con presas y no pueden
evitar el impulso de querer atraparla
entonces eso lleva a ingerir el plástico
que más tarde provoca la muerte exacto
bueno y ustedes ustedes tuvieron alguna
alguna noticia así que les hubiera esta
semana han llamado la atención no sé sin
noticias inéditas pero sin mencionar que
el día de la mujer fue muy importante
también en argentina
un montón de actividades y en argentina
justo está en el marco en el marco de la
legalización la despenalización del
aborto entonces muchas mujeres es un
movimiento enorme muchas por ejemplo la
universidad de buenos aires las
diferentes facultades adhirieron al paro
de mujeres entonces fue un movimiento
enorme que está reclamando
esta nueva esta ley se realizaron
marchas en todo el país pero en buenos
aires hubo una de una masividad inédita
para este tipo de marcha en el que
participaron no solamente mujeres sino
también hombres y muchos chicos y chicas
mejores también entonces mencionar eso
sí y bueno justamente yo ayer para el
día internacional de la mujer entrevisté
a la directora interina de amnistía
internacional del canal francófono y
ella me decía que una de las prioridades
de la organización de amnistía
internacional es justamente eso la
despenalización del aborto y hablaba de
su intervención en algunos países donde
todavía pues las mujeres son condenadas
y click porque por que abortan y
entonces pues esa amnistía está
trabajando para que esa para que se le
espere y de que termine
esa es la condenación del aborto porque
en definitiva los abortos siguen
sucediendo y la idea de que haya una ley
es que sean hechos en instituciones
públicas donde se garantice la la vida
de las mujeres
entonces los abortos ocurren igual la
idea es que estén enmarcado de una
manera que que cuida a la mujer
claro que porque a veces qué es lo que
sucede lo que ha sucedido desde siempre
con que las mujeres recurren a prácticas
clandestinas en las que ponen su vida en
peligro sí y muchas mujeres han muerto
entonces pues la despenalización del
aborto un tema bueno muy bien bueno que
gusto tener la saca en el estudio ya
habíamos tenido la oportunidad de a
principios de año de conversar con las
dos
pero para los que no las que nos están
viendo en este momento por allá en
facebook live
los que no tuvieron la oportunidad de
escuchar son buenas no estaba ocupado
estaba trabajando en fin pero para los
que no pudieron escucharlo entonces
aquí están nuevamente invitadas y
recordémosles justamente mariana
a estas personas que es el instituto que
es legal
el legado es un instituto de transmisión
de la lengua del español y de la cultura
sobre todo las que estamos trabajando de
las culturas latinoamericanas pero bueno
también hablamos de cultura
hispanoamericana
y estamos trabajando con tres programas
la idea original del espacio hace dos
años que empezamos a investigar y a
trabajar fue pensando en en crear un
programa de transmisión del español como
lengua de origen para nuestros
descendientes sabiendo y confirmando lo
al interior de nuestros nuestros hogares
de que a la tercera generación de
inmigrantes la lengua se pierde así que
esa fue como un poquito el motor de
delegados y hoy tenemos un programa
especial diseñado especialmente para
estos chicos que son hispanohablantes
pero que no tienen otras competencias de
la lengua que además aprenden el francés
y el inglés en las escuelas y tenemos
otro programa también para el resto de
la comunidad que le interese la lee muy
nuestra cultura entonces hay un programa
también de español como lengua
extranjera y hay talleres abiertos a
toda la comunidad de hispanohablantes o
no
basados en diferentes artes y siempre
bueno con este este eje puesto en la
mirada latinoamericana vamos a
recordarles a nuestros oyentes o
videntes su escucha veedores que mariana
marín es la co fue la fundadora y
directora de legados él lucía lucía
bueno
tú eres coordinadora de español en
legados y lo decíamos también tú eres
profesora en la flacso
para con respecto a legados cuál es tu
contribución bueno nosotros en flacso
empezamos a investigar con compañeras
también de allá de buenos aires- el tema
de la lengua de herencia que es como los
chicos reciben el español y qué
dificultades qué necesidades tienen para
poder desempeñarse poder desarrollarse
en español desde lo profesional desde lo
académico entonces vinimos en este
convenio entre flacso y legados hace
seis meses a hacer una capacitación a
trabajar con los profesores de acá y
ahora yo volví de vuelta en este marco
para para coordinar digamos el inicio de
las clases entonces
es un proyecto que es muy lindo y me
parece que tiene mucho mucho todavía por
hacer y por crecer como es un tema que
que no se agota resaltó que están
describiendo nuestras invitadas porque
no se trata es evidente de una escuela
hay muchas aquí en montreal canadá es
profesor de español es una de esas veces
me reclaman pero me resisto pero te vas
de rogar en este caso al hígado va a
avanzar más allá se trata de recuperar
no solamente un recuperado de mantener
la lengua sino la cultura en general sí
y en el emprendimiento es bastante nuevo
que respuesta habido hasta ahora
bueno una cosita antes claro el programa
fue diseñado para transmitir en algunos
casos o aprender la lengua a través de
las artes de eso también es como el
pilar y bastante innovador bastante
innovador estamos trabajando con
diferentes disciplinas artísticas en una
con una metodología que se llama de
parejas pedagógicas entonces en el
programa de lengua de herencia
los chicos trabajan con una profesora de
español y con otra profesora en la mitad
de la clase mitad y mitad con una
profesora en una disciplina artística
hacia el teatro el canto y la música la
pintura y siempre con un enfoque
latinoamericanista lo cual además evita
la aburrida clase de gramática española
es el mundo a distribuir ellos no se
enteran pero te digo que han tenido
clases especiales de acentuación de
gramática y ellos pero además el tema es
que el público es lo innovador también
porque son los hijos de latinoamericanos
entonces tienen la lengua la hablan y no
les puedes dar una clase de gramática
tradicional porque te van a mirar como
diciendo no soy no soy francés o yo sé a
hablar pero es recuperar la lengua de
darle un valor que se sientan que puedan
hablar esa lengua desde lo emotivo
también desde desde la argumentación
desde un nivel un poco más abstracto
desde los sensibles como que sea algo
con lo que se puedan expresar en
literatura en poesía en un montón de
cosas entonces no es una clase
tradicional de gramática y bueno digamos
ese también como nuestro proyecto de
laboratorio era pensar un un programa un
espacio que tuviera la lengua como como
eje
digamos tratando de responder a esta
necesidad de esta preocupación de que
nuestros hijos la van a perder a la
lengua pero tratando de transmitirla o
de crear ese vínculo afectivo con
nuestro público a través de las
disciplinas artísticas eso era como para
nosotros en el mundo de adultos de
profesionales yo vengo de la
antropología de los que vienen de
formación en letras de la enseñanza de
la lengua nos parecía como fantástico
pero bueno ahora para responder a tu
pregunta la repercusión que he tenido en
las familias y en los niños es bellísima
tenemos dos clases dos cursos de lengua
de herencia abiertos que ya están han
pasado la mitad de la sesión y bueno al
otro día de la primera clase y todo el
mundo seguía siguió viniendo recibíamos
mensajes y fotos de las mamás de las
desde sus casas diciendo mira está
haciendo los deberes delegados los
chicos llegan corriendo o sea una de las
nenas
los testimonios son son divinos una de
las minas me dijo ah me gusta venir más
acá que la escuela me podés jugar yo
también me formé me guardas para todo el
año que viene mi mamá lo va a pagar
porque yo sigo yo sigo
y eso nos alienta mucho si una de las
chicas dijo una de las primeras clases
la profesora terminó con colorín
colorado este cuento se ha acabado y a
ellas le vino toda la infancia que por
ahí era algo que la madre le decía y
pensaba que era algo más de su relación
con su mamá y de repente sentir que es
una comunidad entera que entiende y que
comparte eso también hace valorar esa
lengua
a mí me gustaría decirle a las personas
que nos están viendo o escucha viendo en
este momento qué bueno si tienen buenos
quizás para para ellos y la gente en
américa latina quizá éste esté la
transmisión de la cultura sea un tema
que finalmente para ellos es algo
natural natural porque se hace en la
vida de todos los días y que al
escucharla cada usted es deber de todo
el trabajo que hay que hacer para que
los inmigrantes y los latinos en este
caso como nosotros podamos
transmitir nuestra cultura a nuestros
hijos pues es un trabajo que necesita
dedicación y además de la dedicación se
necesitan instituciones como las que
ustedes están representando y que han
creado para poder transmitir esa cultura
tenemos acá
rafael bandera pacheco quien desde
barranquilla colombia mi ciudad
barranquilla y rafael es un amigo de
infancia y rafael dice un saludo cordial
desde barranquilla puerta de oro de
colombia este domingo hay elecciones y
también le damos una la bienvenida a
javier gonzález nungaray quien nos está
escuchando javier es un asiduo escucha
veedor del programa casi siempre
presentarse siempre presente sangre
un saludo sabía que se encuentra en
méxico entonces pues invitamos a todos
los que nos están siguiendo en este
momento a que hagan sus preguntas con
respecto a la temática que estamos
abordando hoy aquí en
este programa yo quería preguntarle
clásicas porque hablaron de menores es
solamente menores de edad la clientela
de ligados o también hay adultos hay
adultos también la idea de los talleres
es unir las comunidades no o sea que
venga a gente que pueda hablar español
como lengua materna pero también que
venga gente francófona que sepa francés
sabemos que la gente de acá ama la
cultura latinoamericana entonces hacen
tenemos espacios de cine-debate por
ejemplo donde pasamos las películas en
español habladas en español y después se
hace un debate en español entonces las
personas que tienen un francés
intermedio intermedio avanzado
generalmente ponemos subtítulos eso sí
pueden seguir las películas y seguir la
discusión
y también español claro tiene un nivel
de español claro y también tenemos un
taller de pintura donde hay una
profesora de artes que da la clase de
español perdón la clase de pintura en
español y eso es súper rico desde
y lo cognitivo porque uno está usando
para ser creativo desde lo artístico
también el cerebro desde el lenguaje
entonces eso expande muchísimo la
creación entonces es nuestra idea con
estos talleres es que sean espacios
sociales donde se pueda compartir la
lengua donde se puedan practicar y
también donde las personas
latinoamericanas migrantes puedan
desempeñarse en sus profesiones y
desempeñarse en esas profesiones con su
lengua primera entonces llegue un
público bastante heterogéneo que también
apunta como vos decías a conocer o a
profundizar su conocimiento del español
no por nada en montreal se habla cada
vez más español el español que se
escucha hoy en día en las calles es
mucho más frecuente que el que se
escuchaba hace apenas cuatro años atrás
cuando yo llegué y no son siempre
inmigrantes latinos los que lo hablan
sino que son también muchos canadienses
o específicamente que vemos que están
interesados como decías en la cultura
hispana en la cultura latinoamericana y
que quieren conocer o profundizar sus
conocimientos de lengua así que
el trabajo creo que será bienvenido no
solamente por aquellos que quieren
mantener sus mismos de origen
y después también tenemos cursos de
español como lengua extranjera que es
una persona que francisco francófona que
quiere aprender el español porque va de
viaje o lo que fuere que también nuestro
proyecto futuro es trabajar con personas
mayores de
de la comunidad de montreal en función
de
de trabajar el proceso cognitivo con una
lengua nueva para retrasar la senilidad
también tenemos de ese proyecto vamos
abriendo también pero bueno para
precisar más el programa de lengua de
herencia va desde los 0 hasta los 17
años el problema de lengua del en
ciudades los 0 a los 17 años el programa
de lengua extranjera es para adultos y
jóvenes y adultos limita pero los los
chicos que terminen el programa
delegados a los 17 años pueden seguir en
esto en esto que hemos denominado
talleres del mundo hispano claro que son
todos estos talleres que mencionaba
lucía entonces ahí pueden seguir
trabajando estar inmersos en español en
contacto con la comunidad local sea
francófona u otra
que de hecho bueno hemos tenido en el
taller de cine debate presencia de gente
eeuu mexicano estamos todos mezclados
vamos a regresar las ahorita al cine
debate hay un mensaje que hago también
te deja bien con gonzález nungaray que
acabamos de saludar él dice muchos
saludos amigos de canadá en las américas
café felicitaciones a las mujeres
presentes eso amar a ustedes y a todas
en general por su día el día
internacional de la mujer y les recuerdo
nuevamente a todas las personas que nos
están escuchando que si tienen alguna
pregunta se la pueden hacer directamente
acá a nuestras invitadas que ellas como
un gran placer les van a responder vamos
a leer algunos anuncios algunos mensajes
de nuestros oyentes de louis sí tengo
aquí un mensaje que no tengo la firma no
sé que no envió pero dice rusia presenta
su más alto índice de pobreza en los
diez últimos años
bueno no es algo que yo vi cuando
estudié fuera sí claro que suscribe
solamente moscú ya y rusia es muy grande
a facto es el que envía el mensaje dice
rusia debería diseñar un sistema en
donde la gente no detectará dolor hambre
y pobreza efectos de la carrera
armamentista muy bien yo tengo acá un
mensaje justamente de javier gonzález
nungaray sobre el tema verdad
reconciliación y minería
javier dice colombia el salvador
argentina guatemala etcétera países
donde se han asentado compañías mineras
canadienses y han tenido problemas
legales y de contaminación canadá se
caracteriza por ser un país muy
respetuoso a nivel internacional estas
compañías a mí ver están manchando esa
reputación de canadá saludos amigos del
castor cibernético tengo un mensaje de
esmeralda domínguez ya que estamos
hablando de lengua y de habla y ella
dice la lengua de signos podría ser la
tercera lengua oficial de canadá y
esmeralda domínguez comenta excelente
noticia para las personas sordas
canadienses será que en alguna parte
dictan talleres de lengua de signos
quebequenses
soy intérprete de lengua de señas
venezolana desde hace más de 20 años y
estoy pensando en la posibilidad de
emigrar a quebec sí es cierto que el
lenguaje de las señas pues ahora se está
se está haciendo más popular digamos que
se está integrando más cada vez que hay
un discurso de alguien hay una persona
un traductor que va traduciendo en señas
para las personas que tienen problemas
auditivos y tengo acá un otro mensaje
el tema es granjero canadiense regala su
tierra a una condición entonces josé
lemus dice hola soy jose campesino desde
niño y amante de la naturaleza y de los
animales yo me comprometo solemnemente
de cuidar de su granja y de todos sus
animales incluyendo los más viejos y
desfavorecidos espero su respuesta
entonces no sé quién hizo este tema debe
ser uno de los colegas nuestros el que
hizo el tema no fui yo
pero bueno hay que decir que ya hay un
voluntario al mes para ocuparse de la
tierra de este granjero y las
condiciones cuidar a los animales y
explotar la tierra
la condición tendríamos que haber ido al
reportaje con la entrevista como tal
para conocer la condición porque no no
la tenemos a mano porque si nos en la
tierra gratis
alguna tarea habría que hacer hay que
hay que trabajar la tierra porque ese es
uno de los problemas ahora lo que sucede
acá en en el campo ahora aquí en quebec
por ejemplo hay una migración de la
juventud hacia las ciudades lo cual está
haciendo que las personas que tenían
fincas que tenían granjas lecheras y
todo esto ya están ya están viejas y no
tienen antes eran los hijos los que iban
agarrando el relevo no pero ahora pese
ya hay menos gente me imagino que ese es
el caso de este granjero que debe estar
solo y que nadie para encargarse de su
tierra entonces
ese es el problema que tiene que ser que
los granjeros van envejeciendo y la
juventud está muy poco atraída al
trabajo de campo y bueno pues entonces
va a haber yo tengo la impresión cada
vez más mensajes como este de granjeros
que buscan el relevo y si no les queda
otra vez que vender la tierra
alternativas y debe ser es mayor me
recuerdo cuando llegué aquí a canadá
hace mucho tiempo en 1975 quizá ustedes
no habían nacido
[Risas]
entonces fui a trabajar con un granjero
que era vecino mío y me fui a trabajar
con él y con él pues lo ayudaba en sus
quehaceres
porque sembraba papas y hacía un montón
de cosas y aprendí algo que fue una de
mis primeras lecciones de la vida de
campo aquí en quebec entonces él me
contrataba para que yo lo ayudara porque
no tenía hijos y nadie lo ayudaba
entonces me contrataba a mí para que yo
le ayudara y yo pegué taba recién
llegaba tiene que ver con su acento
vélez entendía prácticamente nada pero
logramos entendernos entonces uno de los
trabajos que hacíamos era ir a recoger
las piedras en el campo antes de sembrar
lo porque él me decía que las piedras
crecen en la tierra como ese
entonces me decía las tierras las
piedras crecen entonces hay que sacarlas
porque si no no podemos sembrar y yo
tenía dificultad no tener en comprender
que era porque era la tierra que sí que
las piedras crece se dice hacía a título
de chiste
en la tierra es tan fértil en américa
latina que siembras un cajón y te sale
un escritorio entonces yo me decía a lo
mejor por hacer una casa que sea no
mentiras entonces lo que sucede es que
como como se congela la tierra en el
momento en que se comienza a descongelar
hay un movimiento de la tierra y ese
movimiento hace que las piedras van
saliendo hacia la superficie
entonces para volver a sembrar para no
dañar las máquinas hay que recoger las
piedras primero antes de la siembra son
todas las piedritas que encuentro en mi
hija pero bueno puede ser las chiquitas
pero de las que te estoy hablando eran
unas señoras hidro tasas y de gramática
que efectivamente yo entendía que si él
pasaba con su máquina a elaborar la
tierra pues seguramente se le dañaba la
maquinaria no porque son una piedra muy
grande y yo que pensaba más de mis
vecinos pero regresivos acá con nuestras
invitadas mariana marín y lucía aguero
si hay mensajes acá
si hay algunos para ustedes leoncio a
nuestro querido leonardo gimeno esta
está escuchando no se está viendo nos
está escuchando nos saludó leonardo a
través en buena compañía como te puedes
dar cuenta y tenemos un comentario de
joshua lines que dice saludos amigos de
canadá en las américas café excelente
programa bueno pues muchas gracias
joshua y vuelvo a repetir la invitación
y les digo que si tienen alguna pregunta
para nuestras invitadas ellas están aquí
justamente para responderles en el cine
debate entonces hablamos desde el cine
debate lo que tú decías es que lo que
ustedes dicen es que es un éxito digamos
está
forma de aprendizaje del idioma y
si desde
si tiene me parece que depende la
persona y después también la familia en
las repercusiones que tienen son
muchísimas y también te invitamos a que
vengas a acompañarnos también luis y
hagan su propia experiencia pero
me parece que si desde un desde un lugar
más generales
volver a recuperar lazos o crear lazos y
lazos que también otro que cuando
conversábamos con lucia lo bonito es que
no estamos
pensando no desde una mirada desde el
pasado hacia el presente sino desde el
presente
recuperando las memorias también pero es
una mirada actual a una mirada
contemporánea son encuentros que parten
de hoy de las vidas que tenemos hoy
aunque después cada cada persona y si
quieres cada latinoamericano está
atravesado por sus propias historias
migratorias sin embargo el legado se
vuelve un espacio de encuentros actuales
contemporáneos la propuesta del cine
también de lo que se está filmando y en
américa latina es justamente cuando las
las primeras conversaciones que teníamos
con lucía era pensándolo corriendo no
desde los lugares más repetitivos o de
mitos o de construcciones y así como
estereotipos estereotipos del cine y sí
nos está yendo bien la gente se interesa
participa le provoca curiosidad y sin
quitarle espesor a las discusiones
tampoco claro o sea te hicimos
proyecciones de películas para niños de
películas de américa latina para niños y
eso fue muy lindo también ver a los
chicos cómo ver toda una película en
español y entenderla y después repetir
frases en español o sentirse movilizados
por eso si por ahí incluso jugar entre
ellos en español entonces ya desde ese
primer lugar nos pareció muy lindo y con
el cine debate para adultos también han
surgido discusiones que exceden a la
experiencia de américa latina que son
también comunes a la experiencia
canadiense nuestra propuesta de des
delegado siempre es trabajar con la
identidad en un sentido amplio y
pensarnos pensarnos como latino
canadienses
no solo desde el estudio estereotipo
latinoamericano o el estereotipo
canadiense entonces son películas que
invitan a la reflexión con temas
actuales que son globales entonces
no teníamos la programación ya preparada
desde hace una semana y bueno tuvimos la
noticia de que la película que se
transmite esta noche proyecto esta noche
ganó el oscar la mejor película de
animación así que esta noche estamos con
coco se va a llenar la sala entonces
tenemos otra función el domingo las 17
horas
un comentario acá de javier gonzález
nunca árabe que dice buen comentario
pablo con respecto al caso de las
piedras en el que íbamos a louis el
tiempo siempre pasa volando creemos que
tenemos mucho tiempo pero finalmente se
va como agua entre los legos que resalta
tú esta semana de más trabajo de tu
trabajo hablamos cuando comenzamos la
emisión del día internacional de la
mujer y a propósito de eso yo entrevisté
a leonor se dijo que es una consultora
en salud laboral e investigador asociado
a la cátedra de leyes en salud y
seguridad laboral la cargo la doctora
catherine de piel en la universidad de
ottawa y ella
refiere al tema de mujer y trabajo la
mujer se ha ido incorporando a tareas
que antes estaban consideradas como
meramente masculinas pero lo que
sostiene zedillo es que la normativa y
las pautas que rigen esas funciones hoy
en día compartidas hoy en día mixtas no
han sido adecuadas con la velocidad
necesaria y que entonces la mujer se ve
a veces enfrentada a tareas que no han
sido legisladas de la manera correcta
ella fue a su vez la impulsora del
primer congreso internacional de salud
mujer y trabajo que se llevó a cabo hace
10 años se están cumpliendo 10 años
ahora en mexico y mantuvimos una
entrevista bastante interesante con ella
que está en línea a partir de hoy así
que los invito a todos a acceder a
nuestro sitio en internet www r6 net
punto ósea y escuchar esta entrevista a
leonor zedillo y bueno yo también y su
hija bueno ya que hablamos también desde
el día de la mujer no compartirles que
hay esto en un festejo en el consulado
mexicano de mujeres que son tal vez
menos conocidas pero
de unas trayectorias muy interesantes
todas trabajadoras en quebec que
compartían el camino que han hecho de ir
abriéndose espacios no solo en el mundo
de los hombres
son mujeres que han destacado un poco
cuéntame en la línea lo que decías voz
una de ellas en neurociencias que eran
espacios en trabajo en laboratorio muy
reservados
a los hombres pero no solo desde ahí
sino también desde como migrantes como
la trabajadora inmigrante debe ir
pasando esas fronteras hasta hasta
llegar a vernos en los lugares donde
queremos estar y si me parece que es un
camino que se presenta más dificultoso
que para los hombres afortunadamente
pues que se está recorriendo el camino
seguro que hay barreras pero cada vez
más yo creo que hay atrás una sola digo
yo desde mi punto de vida de mi punto de
vista de hombres de ustedes de mujeres
de lo más concreto esta es la semana de
relax y para estar acá también hay gente
que tiene que estar cuidando a los
chicos en la casa entonces nosotras
hasta el tiempo ya el tiempo pasa como
agua entre los dedos decíamos ahorita y
ya nos quedan solo un minuto o dos
minutos yo por mi parte los invito a
escuchar una entrevista que hice con una
fotógrafa canadiense de aquí de montreal
ella se llama heidi hollinger
y bueno que es interesantísimo la
entrevista por dos razones la primera
razón por qué ella presenta esta semana
que viene su libro que se llama 300
razones de amar la habana entonces ella
pues pasa la mitad de su vida en la
habana y la otra mitad acá y canadá es
una mujer políglota que habla seis
idiomas y entre ellos el español
yo le entrevisté en español justamente y
ella estuvo viviendo muchos años en
rusia estuvo viviendo diez años en rusia
fue la primera fotógrafa extranjera en
ser contratada por pravda para trabajar
en práctica
de hecho aprendí que en pravda en ruso
quiere decir la verdad entonces pues
algo es algo que aprendí entonces es una
entrevista con heidi hollinger 300
razones para amar la habana y bueno pues
el tiempo de la última intervención para
nuestras invitadas por favor
métanse en nuestra página que es liga
dos puntos sea métanse en el facebook
donde vamos a estar publicando todos los
eventos y la programación y si tienen
cualquier duda nos escriben seguimos
recibiendo chicos para la próxima sesión
están a viernes y bueno muchas gracias
están abiertas las inscripciones para la
próxima sesión que comienza el 14 de
abril los invitamos a que nos acompañen
a que se apropien del proyecto y también
un agradecimiento especial a toda la
gente que nos está apoyando
profesionales desde argentina desde
otros países la gente que está
trabajando acá con nosotros nuestras
familias
muchísimas gracias a vos también
gracias a ti gracias mariana
graciaslucía por habernos acompañado hoy
gracias luis laborda en los controles
técnicos soy chantal sin saber aquí en
la represa hoy en la a cargo de la web
está su mente así gracias
y bueno pues no nos podemos despedir sin
decirles adiós a los espías no sea que
ellos siempre nos están escuchando
porque les gusta el español entre otras
cosas porque este programa y les guste
el programa entonces eso fue todo para
este castor cibernético de este fin de
semana
holt 891 9 10 y 11 de marzo entonces así
nos despedimos y le decimos adiós y
hasta la próxima